- Hey, you've never used
that memory changing thing
on me, have you?
- No, why are you asking?
- Okay good.
Bird seed!
What the hell is
this doing here?
- I--
- You know, that's funny.
I've always loved birds.
I mean, maybe this is a sign.
Maybe I should get one.
What do you think?
- No, no, no, no.
Definitely not, okay?
I hate birds.
They smell, they squawk,
and once you get one
you're gonna get attached,
you're not gonna want
to get rid of it.
I think it's a bad idea.
- Okay, fine, geeze.
I won't get a bird.
What?
That's weird.
I just got a comment on a video
I don't even remember posting.
Can you say I love you?
- I love you Jeff.
Look, look, he's dancing!
(laughing) It
tickles, it tickles.
I had a pet bird?
And you killed him, didn't you?
Didn't you?
(electric buzzing)
Oh well anyways,
like I was saying,
thank you so much for making
me those pumpkin muffins.
They were delicious.
♪ Three aliens came from the sky
♪ The galactic council sent them
♪ And here's the reason why